we're going to begin with breaking news
overnight this one from Capitol Hill
after very intense negotiations the
house passed a bipartisan deal to raise
the U.S debt ceiling and avoid a
possibly catastrophic default now the
Senate is on a very tight deadline to
pass this bill Nicole Killian is on
Capitol Hill where as you know not
everybody is happy about what is
happening Nicole don't they know on
Capitol Hill you never get exactly what
you want good morning to you hey good
morning to you Gail President Biden
seems to be pretty happy about it he
actually watched this vote and he said
that the house has taken a critical step
forward to preventing a first ever
default and he thanks speaker McCarthy
for negotiating this deal in good faith
the bill is passed after days of
non-stop negotiations and intense debate
start solving the problem that caused
the nation to max out the credit card
default on our debt would be
catastrophic a bipartisan vote in the
house to raise the nation's debt limit
what is your biggest takeaway from this
process well no one thought it would be
easy a lot of people thought they
couldn't you could never get it speaker
Kevin McCarthy took a Victory lap after
the vote tonight we all made history
because this is the biggest cut and
savings this Congress has ever voted for
the fiscal responsibility act lifts the
debt ceiling through early 2025 giving
the us more borrowing power to pay its
bills but it slashes federal spending in
return clawing back unused coveted money
and IRS funding loosening environmental
rules and imposing stricter work
requirements for those on food
assistance I hope we can move the bill
quickly here in the Senate and bring it
to the president's desk as soon as
possible Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
placed the bill on the Senate calendar
late last night to Fast Track a vote by
week's end but nearly a dozen Senators
have come out against it including
Vermont's Bernie Sanders this whole
process is totally absurd he worries the
proposed Cuts go too deep and would
disproportionately impact low-income
Americans how do you justify voting
against something that would allow the
nation well you can't sometimes you have
to stand up for what's right the
American people in my view are sick and
tired of seeing deficit reduction come
on the backs of working people who are
struggling
some Senator Republicans say the cuts
don't go far enough Kentucky's Rand Paul
wants a vote on an alternative plan
while Utah's Mike Lee says the GOP
should block this bill and has
threatened to slow it down Nate it's
uh I'll take this one Nicole thank you
very much